The Joe Rogan experience to bun. Boom. Hotep Jesus, how are you sir?
I always wanted to say that you wanted to call somebody that I need that drama.
I haven't fucked to get a name like Hotep Jesus. How'd that come about?
It wasn't my idea. You know, I was uh, I had just went through my, uh,
spiritual awakening.
I just loved the hip hop industry and I went through like that mace thing,
you know, you go to [inaudible] are you doing with the headgear?
We got you a lot. A lot going on up there. I had to top my head down.
It's a black gay man.
So you a spiritual awakening. I had this spiritual awakening and um, you know,
tweeting on Twitter like I do, right? And uh, somebody said,
what do you think you are some kind of Hotep Jesus. Ooh, that's good. Like Ooh,
yes, I do think I'm Hotep Jesus. That's perfect. And now you own it.
That person is probably like, fuck God damn it. That was a great name.
I gave that dude. Yeah.
I don't know who that person is or was or where they are. Now.
Shout out to whoever you are exactly and vibe. Hi, your Twitter.
Why didn't you switch it to Hotep? Jesus, can you switch it? Oh,
does anybody own Hotep? Jesus, I do you so you have Hotep Jesus on Twitter too.
Yeah, I reserved it. Oh dude. I think they could probably swap.
Do you have a cute little blue check marks yet? No. What the fuck is that?
How do you get one of those? I don't know. People,
there's some people that have those that have like a thousand followers know.
Yeah. How are you getting,
like if you worked for the New York times or some shit you had go,
I'll do Joe and then I get verified. I don't know how Twitter feels about me.
I mean I think Jack likes me. He's been in a couple of times,
but I think the whole, they're, they're weird man. They weren't,
I mean I think all social media,
all tech companies want you to tow a line right now.
And if you're not towing that line and you're bringing on forbidden guests and
you have people that have controversial ideas, you know,
they'll have that finger on the button of getting rid of you.
They don't know what to do.
It's just like radio, you know, like radio.
A lot of people don't know about a radio has to play happy songs cause happy
people buy things. Yeah, that's what, that's what the studies say. Allegedly.
The marketing studies and advertising studies say people who are in a good mood
tend to buy things. Right.
So the radio is supposed to play happy songs all day long and the radio works
for the advertisers, kind of like media and so on, so forth.
So social media is no different. They have advertises.
So if there's people on the platform who are creating disgruntled crowds,
it could be hurting the bottom line.
Yeah. But Facebook's algorithm actually favors that.
The way Facebook has it set up. Like say if, if you, uh,
if you get into debates with people on abortion or something like very
controversial, they will start sending that shit to your feet. They will,
they will prop you. It will, it will,
they'll sort of steer it in your direction because the more you engage,
the more clicks they get, the more money they get, the more advertising dollars.
Again,
truly. Absolutely. Uh,
the Facebook algorithm is quite unique in the way that things can go viral
there. Um, Twitter, I feel like
that the Twitter safety and council, what do they call it? Trust and safety.
Is that what it's called? Something like that. Yeah.
So when I go and look at the entities that contribute to that board,
I kind of start saying, Oh, okay, I see why certain topics are taboo. You know?
Um, there's, when you, when there's a board,
those people on the board are the voice. They're the ones that have the opinion,
you know? So if your group isn't represented,
maybe you need to figure out how to get on that board. You know what I mean?
Right. I don't know.
Anybody's getting on that board not is not going to happen and you better be
left wing. You're going to get on that board. I don't think there's any. Right.
What do you think is, I think Jack's more like in the middle. Yes.
I think he's closer to the middle. I don't think it's Jack. I think it's,
you know, Jack's working on a bunch of different projects,
but I think it's probably, you know,
whoever else is in the office making the day to days decisions. Yeah,
I like Jack a lot,
but I think Jack is in the middle of a gigantic corporation and there's so many
people with so many ideas. Essentially
the founding fathers of our country had a great idea when it comes to freedom of
expression.
They felt like it was very important that you have free speech and the only,
you can't be silenced. You can't be,
you can't be undermined by people who disagree with you because it's dangerous.
It's dangerous when someone can just decide that you can't have a voice anymore
and only their voice can be heard.
And we're kind of seeing that with Twitter and we're kind of seeing that with
Facebook and with Google and they're,
they're deciding what can be heard and what not can be heard.
They think they're doing it for good reasons.
They think they're doing it to preserve our culture and our civilization and
they want to protect people from the election. Read it. Shut down the Donald,
the uh, the, the Donald Trump support a Reddit page. Yeah.
That's not a good idea. That right.
Right before the Dem Dem to be right before the democratic debate and you know,
that was like where all the funny memes come from and look man, this,
you can't do that. I mean,
just because if you have some people that are saying some shit that's bad on
there, get rid of those people. Get rid of that.
But you can't just shut down a whole forum. Like it seems, that seems insane.
Is there a reason for it? It's not shut down. It says it's quarantined. Fuck.
Does that mean is it have a disease for like temporary, it's got Ebola,
it's happens to people. They got to do something.
It says there's violent threats. I'm looking to see what repeated misbehavior.
Violent threats. Skeptical.
Very. Seems weird, right?
I feel like all this stuff is like we're seeing what the first amendment is
really all about, why it exists.
We're seeing it play out with all these social media sites. I really think that,
you know, my thing is with like the right thing, right?
It's very easy to create an actor, right?
The left can create a right wing actor online to pretend like it's something,
and I'm sure it's something else. They can go in and read Reddit,
do something malicious to get the whole Reddit band right.
Or an agent provocateur. Exactly. And uh,
I never leave that off the table. When I look at instances like this,
when you say, Oh, somebody was, it's the internet, everybody's anonymous,
you know, you tracking this back to who it is, you know what I mean?
Or do you know what's conservative? Do you know? Is it Republican? Are you sure?
So, you know, I take these things,
these pieces of information with a grain of salt. Yeah, you should.
But is this election meddling? It kind of is, right?
Is what it feels like if you're killing a whole sub, what does it depends.
I mean, so if they're really,
that would be really interesting if it turns out that it was someone from the
left that was posing as someone from the right in order to shut down a forum and
pretend there's death threats or, I mean, you look at YouTube, right?
And what's been happening with YouTube? Uh, even just the algorithm, you know,
uh, I'm pretty good with keywords. I do SEO marketing,
so when I type in certain keywords or find certain things,
I know what's gonna come up or what type of content comes up.
Now when I type in those keywords, it's like ABC, NBC, ABC, CNN,
and I'm like, that's not what I wanted.
They don't even talk about these keywords. What are you talking about? You know?
So when you start seeing that,
you start thinking about ink sock in Orwell in 1984,
socialism and communism and fascism and, ah,
the degradation of society and, um,
a lot of control coming down. Um, you know, people,
you know, in some ways it's like,
was the internet created for freedom or was it country created for control?
Right? So it's two different pathways. You could probably look at that.
But it seems like in many ways they set us up to be controlled and they're doing
it through monopolies.
Google controls search through YouTube and Google.
And by what you search, you can think it's a truth. But what did Kanye say?
Kanye say Google lied to you. You know,
so Johnny says a lot of crazy shit though. You never really think about that.
He does. And I like crazy. I do too. I'm a big fan of crazy. I'm a little crazy.
A lot of crazy sometimes,
so I appreciate his crazy side more than his calm side. Hmm.
Well great things come from wild thoughts. Right? Exactly.
I think the internet was initially created to exchange information and then when
it got loose to the general public, they realize what a crazy idea that was.
Well,
I think we're seeing right now with the algorithms is that these corporations
are influencing these companies to say, Hey,
when someone's looking for these things, how about you send them over to ABC?
How about you send them over to NBC? How about you? You know,
like we want to be able to get the first views on these things.
So if someone's searching for that, I don't know how they do it.
I dunno what they, whether they have agreements with them, maybe.
I mean there's also a lot of copywritten shit that's on there that could get
YouTube in some trouble if they ever really decided to pursue it. Right.
And how many videos are on YouTube that people have on their channel that are
just straight off of Fox news or NBC news or there's a lot of like copyright
protected content that YouTube is essentially profiting off of. Oh yeah,
yeah. They make a ton of money off that stuff. Um,
so they might have deals where they say, look, we'll send these people to,
you know, this first. Yeah. And that's why I say, you know,
and that's where the control comes in. You know, the advertisers,
advertisers are the ones paying, you know, for the platform to a thing.
It's not us to users that are paying for a YouTube spree. So who's paying,
right? They're there, they're monetizing us, they're monetizing us to users.
And the viewers. Yeah. That's where it gets tricky, right?
Because as soon as the advertisers get on board, they said, look, we, uh,
you know, we want to give you money,
but this content is not advertiser friendly. Right? Yeah.
And then they start moving stuff around and demonetizing things and,
and with demonetization, the real thing that they're doing and a lot of ways,
whether it's intentional or not, is you're influencing what people post.
You're kind of, you're asking them to self-censor cause if you say, Hey,
you guys want to discuss abortion rights or you know, like there's,
there's some things that you start discussing them and they will automatically
dump demonetize you. Yeah. Well who is the girl that put out the, uh,
abortion documentary? Right. And H girls snatched that down.
I forget what it's called. Um, I'm bad at memorizing these things,
but there was an, uh,
basically an anti abortion thing that exposed some things about abortion as a
documentary. And I believe that day it went up, it got shut down.
She had to re upload it. Um, what's that? Lauren? Southern might've been. Yeah.
There's those two cute white chicks that everybody thinks are super racist.
Lauren Southern and Tammy, Tammy, Lauren, Tomi Lahren, Tommy Lauren.
So she did a documentary, but then you have like a,
the James O'Keefe thing where he put up the exposing a YouTube and in that got,
you know,
obviously they're gonna take it down for the most recent one that exposed
Google. Right, right. Yeah. I've been asking people about that. I'm like, okay,
break this down for me.
Is there any way that this could have been deceptively advertised or deceptively
edited? Like it's,
it seems to me like they're saying that they're going to manipulate search
results and they're gonna manipulate the way people see things because of the
2016 election. They don't want that happening again in 2020.
That's what it seems when I'm looking at it. Absolutely. That's exactly,
it looks like could it be docked? Of course. Good. You know, that's, that's,
that's always possible. But, um,
when you go and experience it for yourself, like what I was talking about with,
you know, doing a keyword search, you start seeing the power willows.
Um, and then, you know, uncle Hotep, you know, he is, his channel was, you know,
doing great. And then the algorithm flipped and they see no,
like he wasn't making the same money anymore.
So it's like I don't have to go to some doctor video or whatever video to
understand his problem. The people around me are being affected by it. You know,
this is a primary source. I don't have to look at some money on internet. Um,
but I dunno, it's, it's
in a way I don't like playing victim with the topic, right.
Steer platform, do what you want with it. We choose to be there.
We don't have to be, there does not another game in town though. It's not,
it's weird, right?
When you think about how big the internet is and there's only one YouTube,
right? And Vimeo and all those other ones, they're great. But well, you know,
I always relate it to the black community. You know,
the black community always say, Oh, you know, white people,
this white people that white people just swipe it would ask,
they're not giving us opportunity. And it's always like, well,
is that the only opportunity? Can you not create your own opportunity?
You know what I mean? So I never want to take a victim mentality and say, Oh,
you know, let's take Google to court. You know, all this stuff. It's like,
if you want to do that, that's fine. That's not how I'm looking at this.
I'm looking at it longterm, like hooking up Andrew Torb over at gap,
you know what I mean? And building tools. So, you know, we do a,
the coin bits app.com and uh, creators can actually, um, it's,
it's based upon approval right now,
but creators can go on there and receive Bitcoin as a donation, you know,
so we're circumventing the things that happen,
like with the de platforming at Patriot, right?
And the other payment platforms for creators.
So we're creating tools to circumvent these things. So that's how I look at it.
I'm like, Oh, Google is doing this. Great. This is a great opportunity here.
Let me seize it and let me build it. And B, you know, the alternative, you know,
I love to see that. Um,
is the alternative going to be YouTube and as popular? Of course not,
it's just not, but it's still a viable option.
You can still communicate with your people.
The number one communication tool for an influencer, what their,
what their row community is. Email, build your email list, right?
People still subscribe to your email lists, right? That's not YouTube.
That's not Google. That's your email list. That's your contact list.
So it's like, you can complain about YouTube or Google,
but you can build your audience almost anywhere.
It depends on how powerful you are.
Are you powerful enough to convince people to come to this other platform or to
wherever you are?
A lot of people are powerful enough to pack a room at $2,000 a ticket.
You tell them you can't get somebody to go to another platform for free.
Who charges $2,000 a ticket. Uh, I mean, a lot of these speakers, you know,
like the Tony Robbins type cats, he charges 2000 bucks. I think Charles like 10.
Yeah. I think, I think some of his stuff is like 10,
but he's doing like these week long events where everybody gets together.
I'm going to turn your large doing karate kicks and shit
when you would ask how you get the biggest check,
you've got to create a bigger experience. So it's like, all right,
so we'll do a one day at two K right? It's like, well, how do I get 10 K?
It's like, well, let's just extend it for the week and you know, add like,
you know, the kickboxing class and you know, we'll chat
in a sauna. You just, you know, create that part of the marketing, you know?
Yeah. Um, but yeah, I'm not complaining about these tech companies,
these tech companies. Man, I'm not scared of these dudes, man. He did.
The content is us. The content is certainly us.
And I get what I got from talking to Jack and Vigia was it's almost impossible
to manage a site like that.
The the just the influx of not like I used to have a message board or my website
and one of the things that I noticed before we shut it down was I was getting
thousands and thousands of Russian emails that were signing up for my website.
This is what you remember that Jamie [inaudible], this is years ago,
this is like three years ago. Okay. I mean fucking fat,
like tens of thousands of Russian email addresses.
We're signing up like similar addresses. It was something like the IRA,
something like the internet research agency,
which does that which is responsible for all those fake pages on Facebook and
Google and Instagram and all that shit.
And they were signing up for websites and that had message boards and then they
would jump on and pretend that they were whatever the fuck they were,
pretend that they were a social justice warrior,
pretend that there was black lives matter and they just start fights,
start arguments. And it was like, wow, this is fascinating. And then when it,
when it also happened,
and then it happened with Facebook and it became a big part of the election.
You realize like this is like concerted effort to use these platforms to wiggle.
So when your Jack or your, whoever runs goo, you have to look at that and go,
okay, hello. Fuck, do we manage that? I mean, if we're in a free speech,
we should just let these people manipulate everybody, right? Let it be wild,
wild West.
[inaudible].